hello and welcome again to Beth Rigby
interviews on this week's show one of
the great survivors of Donald Trump's
White House Mike Pompeo served as both
the director of the CIA and Secretary of
State he tells me why current President
Joe Biden appears weak to Vladimir Putin
and why the world should fear China's
leader more than Russia's
[Music]
as fears grow of a new Russian offensive
Mike Pompeo tells me the West has been
too slow to send weapons to help Ukraine
but it's not Vladimir Putin we should
fear the most according to secretary
Pompeo he thinks China's leader wants to
dominate the world and I asked secretary
Pompeo whether he regrets statements
made in the aftermath of the capital
riots When Donald Trump tried to
overturn the 2020 election there will be
a smooth transition to a second Trump
Administration
right we're ready
secretary pompeo's take on that moment
in history is definitely worth waiting
for but fast we turn to his new Memoir
never give an inch and talked about what
it was like working in the Trump
Administration
so Chic Pompeo thank you so much for
joining us on the show today you were
the Great survivor of the Trump
Administration you stayed with him
throughout his four years do you regard
him as having been a great president
the work that we did has was pretty
remarkable I think it will absolutely
stand the test of time the the legacy is
hard to predict but if you look at the
changes made in the Middle East with the
Abraham Accords if you look at the
United States for the first time in
goodness 40 plus years we challenged the
Chinese Communist party that had
destroyed millions of jobs in our
country uh we put America first we put
religious freedom at the front of what
we are doing and we delivered on behalf
of the American people in a way that
protected them from ever having to
support a war in Europe all of those
things we were successful at and I noted
in your book you said um I would do it
all again and I might so maybe we'll
come on to that in a bit
I'm happy to take that on you know it's
a uh you don't get these opportunities
in life uh very often you had folks in
the administration that decided it
wasn't for them they didn't want to be
part of it it was a very noisy
Administration we suffered under the
Russia hoax for two and a half years so
it was tough sledding for sure but I
would if given the opportunity
absolutely do everything again I I do a
few things better we didn't get it right
every single day but I am incredibly
proud of the effort that we made and the
outcomes that we got and such a problem
I will certainly come back to that and a
bit but what I wanted to start off
talking to you about was the Pompeo
Trump philosophy when it came to foreign
policy this quote really struck me from
the book it you wrote this those that
assume the best of human beings
especially if authoritarian Leaders with
track records of inhumanity and
aggression are doomed to fail thus the
progressive philosophy
that will cease Harmony that Wars will
cease and Harmony will reign if we have
more talks more tolerance more
concession more U.N governments less
American presence in the world is
completely naive it causes wicked men
such as Kim ji and Putin to salivate
I was interested in that because in the
book A lot of it is about you actually
engaging with those people trying to
talk to them trying to negotiate trying
to strike deals
so you're quite critical when the
Democrats do it but but you did it
yourself
oh goodness uh nothing could be further
from the truth it's not about the
engagement this is the problem that the
progressive left has in their outlook on
the world they they assume that others
want to be more like you and me XI
xingping no more wants to be like you or
me than a man in the moon chairman Kim
the same Vladimir Putin that they don't
understand human dignity they don't
understand property rights and decency
these are people who have a value set
that is so disconnected so it's not
about the engagement happy to talk to
them I did I met with the Taliban I met
with Xi Jinping I bet with chairman Kim
too many times but we were never about
the engagement we never came home and
said great we had a great conversation
it was lovely boy we've made a lot of
progress because we were all just
sitting in the room it's not about
process it's about delivering I want to
talk to you about some of these leaders
because there's lots of
um
really colorful uh parts of the book
where you talk about these these
meetings with with people that very few
people actually meet so let's start off
with North Korea's Kim Jong-un you were
under No Illusion about the sort of man
you were dealing with where you called
him a killer a man who starved his own
people what was it like meeting him it
was really something uh uh for someone
like me who goodness in 2009 was running
a machine shop in Wichita Kansas uh to
be on a plane as CI director on Atlantis
admission flying on Easter weekend of
2018 to meet this fella who not only
started his own people but he killed an
American
Otto warmbier had been in detention in
North Korea and had come home and died
from his mishandling there his
maltreatment there he was evil and we
knew it but we had an objective one that
we ultimately weren't successful in but
to get him to give up his weapons of
mass destruction and we'd watched 30
years of effort we tried to go at it a
different way by offering him a good
solution for himself for his people and
for all of Asia and in the end we were
unsuccessful we stopped his long-range
missile testing he didn't conduct any
nuclear tests so his program did not
Advance on our watch but in the end our
objective was not successful
I mean even Donald Trump meeting uh
chairman Kim was a huge moment wasn't it
and and in a way elevated chairman Kim
because it kind of invited him into the
family of Nations if you like what did
you get in return for doing that
yeah that I think that utter nonsense
and again this is a story of the left
about how they think about the world the
same way we do chairman chairman Kim's
no more on the world stage and invited
into the community of Nations today we
can prove this right here we are two
years on when's the last time chairman
Kim went to a a g anything meeting
right by meeting with president or with
chairman Kim president Trump no more
brought chairman Kim into the community
of Nations than a man in the moon this
is falder all this is silliness of the
progressive left what we got was we got
him to slow his program down and you
should note the moment we left office
the moment I left a secretary of state
he started launching missiles at a rate
he had never launched missiles before
and it sounds like he's going to conduct
a nuclear test we'd convinced him not to
do that yeah that's a good thing it was
progress but I'm happy to concede that
there is a lot of work that remains to
be done but to suggest somehow that
chairman Kim's now good and Noble person
because Donald Trump met with him is
just
it was rather it was rather that it
elevated him to something because of the
importance of having the best time
you know the world leader that was
rather the point I was put into you but
I just I just think it's counterfactual
that's all I think that's just what what
one other thing I I want to ask you
about because you talk about the joint
declaration
and you've got a declaration from North
Korea which said they were working
toward the complete denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula now I can tell from
your book that you are a guy that
doesn't much like diplomatic
communicates if they don't amount to
much and in the end that's what you said
clawed isn't it it was a a commitment
that he didn't follow through on you
must have been disappointed with that
yes no that's that's true terribly
disappointed you don't often find
leaders who are prepared to talk about
the things they didn't get right they
usually want to just focus on their
successes uh we we didn't get this one
done I was terribly disappointed the
chairman Kim in Hanoi did not live up to
the commitment that he had made to us I
think in large measure and I write about
this and never give an inch I think Xi
Jinping in China got to him told him no
don't do it Jeremy Kim is certainly not
free to do whatever he wants he's highly
dependent on the Chinese Communist party
and sexually when you look back on your
tenure as secretary of state was this
the biggest regret for you the biggest
disappointment that you couldn't bring
in North Korea in the way you wanted to
yes it was unfortunate and that for me
it's not a personally disappointing to
me I don't think about it that way just
as the victories aren't mine either uh
what saddens me is that the world
remains at risk from this guy in North
Korea who has a nuclear capability that
threatens us all and which is escalating
um but let me bring you quickly to
another leader
um in your wicked access as as I well
you write that they're wicked men
president XI you've met with him you've
met with President Putin too you talk
about she as having dead eyes and say of
the dozens of world leaders I met he was
among the most unpleasant what do you
mean by dead eyes and what was so
unpleasant about him
you know um when you sit down with
people even with uh chairman Kim we we
would have a good Communications there
was some level of interactivity just
human activity that you have when human
beings are sitting together uh none of
that existed in my interactions with Xi
Jinping uh he was focused on his vicious
objective there was no small talk if you
challenged anything about his recitation
of History which you knew to be
counterfactual uh he would bark uh he
was he was not someone who you could sit
down with and say well we at least had a
conversation we hurt each other out I
think it's clear he now understands the
American position I never walked away
believing any of that for a second he
was always on transmit as were Wang Yi
and yang jise the two my two
counterparts in China they were always
on transmit their their model of
interaction with the rest of the world
is different even than some of the other
Bad actors they are determined sorry you
talk about his vicious objective what is
that he wants to own you
he wants to own America yeah he wants to
he wants to own he wants hegemonic
intent to cross the world with his
Marxist leninist vision and Chinese
economic and political dominance in
every corner of the world that that's
his vicious objective by the way don't
quote me quote him he's pretty clear
about this the great struggle he owns
and the West all of us who believe in
basic human rights Dignity of every
individual religious freedom property
rights decency this is not Xi Jinping
and we have an obligation to the Next
Generation to push back and that leads
me quite neatly on to my next question
because you say she is the most
dangerous man in the world you know here
we are in Europe on the other side of of
the big pond uh Putin's just launched a
war in Europe do you still thinks she's
more dangerous than Putin absolutely
not not even close
why
Vladimir Putin has a very capable
nuclear program and an economy that is
dependent on a single industry and if we
produce energy in America that industry
would be in a lot less valuable to him
when the Biden team came in they
literally generated 30 billion dollars a
month worth of increased profits to fund
this war against Vladimir Putin we know
how to fix this Europe has the capacity
to defend itself if it will take up
those tools Xi Jinping is a different
creature the globe is dependent on him
economically he has 1.4 billion people
although his population shrank last year
he has an economy that Rivals the size
of that of the United States of America
a highly capable space and Military and
cyber program and that's the
capabilities and we have now also seen
his intention Vladimir Putin has no as
much as he believes in Greater Russia
and going after all of Europe he has no
Illusions about his capacity to dominate
the world Xi Jinping believes this is
not falder all in his he believes he's
going to dominate the world those are
two fundamentally different risks for
our way of life in Europe in the United
States in Asia and the Middle East
everywhere in your book you address the
issue of Ukraine and you say the world
could learn from the Trump
administration's example of drawing
clear lines of deterrence and then
defending them relentlessly you think
Trump would have done a better job on
Ukraine Russia than Biden well let's
look at the facts I'm all about data and
facts Putin hasn't changed I met with
him he's a bad guy I looked in his eyes
I didn't see his soul uh I saw evil make
no mistake about he is the bad guy what
changed
in the last decade in 2014 President
Obama allows Putin to take Crimea
one-fifth of Ukraine we always think
about this war as having started on
February 24th now almost exactly a year
ago it actually started in 2014.
then for four years Putin doesn't invade
Europe doesn't take another single inch
and then we leave office and he goes at
it again I believe I believe that's not
coincidence I believe it is because we
were serious we had put his economy In
Harm's Way We built the American
Military we had created a situation
where NATO members put 480 billion
dollars more into NATO which is one of
the stories is that we hated NATO
somehow asked Secretary General
stoltenberg who helped him create the
NATO that is doing such a good job
supporting Ukraine today we we were the
force although we didn't make many
friends doing it we were the force that
began that trajectory and I think Putin
could see that he saw what we did in the
Middle East to qasim suleimani he could
see we were serious he watched Us in
Afghanistan defend things that mattered
I think there was just a fundamentally
different understanding in the mind of
Vladimir Putin and you you know this
deterrence depends on your adversary's
perception of risk and I think he
thought there was a lot of risk if he
did under our watch and I think he
thought there was no risk doing it when
President Biden was so you so you think
Sanctuary Pompeo that Trump
frightened Putin more than Biden does it
last week though Trump said if I were
president the Russian Ukraine war would
never have happened but even now if
president I would be able to negotiate
and end this horrible and rapidly
escalating War within 24 hours such a
tragic waste of human life that's Donald
Trump on the 26th of Jan
um but but I put it to you that in a way
Biden looks like he's actually been the
War General he's leading the Allies he's
corralled the West he stood up to do
that while Trump is actually laying the
ground for a peace compromise and it's
in the comment from president Trump
whatever
um here's what I know about what we did
right I always you everybody wants to
talk about this random speculation let's
just look at the fact you say President
Biden's the War General yeah it's true
he allowed the war to happen
the tragedy here is that this began this
is the thing that I don't understand
folks ask me all the time Mike would
this have happened if you were still
there and all I can answer I can't prove
the counter factual I'm not still there
but I can promise you that it didn't
happen while I was there doesn't that
seem like good evidence that we could
have continued that model of deterrence
in this in the in the same vein that
Ronald Reagan had peace through strength
I think the Trump Administration nailed
that and we stopped Vladimir Putin from
invading Europe after he had already
taken a fifth of Crimea under our
predecessor okay let me put it another
way
um it suggests a sort of willingness on
the part of of your former boss who you
work so close with to do a deal with
Putin would you back that approach now
secretary on Pompeo and start broker in
a peace deal
this will end with a negotiated solution
if history is any guide to how this
conflict ends I think that's absolutely
true you can count on one hand the
number of conflicts that have ended
through the total decimation of the
enemy of pure capitulation
and so this will end that way sorry to
interrupt you I didn't mean to to see
like I'm jumping in but obviously some
of the discussions are does Crimea stay
Annex does the donbass uh go back to
Ukraine does it stay in the hands of put
like what does a negotiation if you were
there in the hot seat now what would the
negotiated solution look like to you sir
it would begin with the following the
United States and most importantly
Europe actually providing the tools that
the Ukrainian people need to fight and
defend their own sovereignty to put
president zielinski and the Ukrainian
people in the position where President
Putin would be negotiating from weakness
the ultimate resolution they will have
to sort their way through but make no
mistake about it the fact that we the
West dawdled the fact that Schultz
wasn't able to make a commitment to
provide tanks the fact that we knew that
this war was going to begin in September
of the year before the attack and we did
nothing to deter and stop it that put
amazing pressure on Ukraine and has
resulted in the death of thousands of
ukrainians Vladimir Putin is responsible
for these deaths but make no mistake
about it the West has been slow and late
and fearful of escalation and that
that's been a mistake and so we should
do our best to fix that today we should
provide them the things that they need
and put Ukraine and the West in a place
where Vladimir Putin will see the
handwriting on the wall this is how you
restore deterrents were you talking
about more military equipment are you
talking about fighter jets are you
talking about a no-fly zone what do you
mean when you say he give him what he
needs yes my point is this we're a year
in
and president zelinski has been asking
for the capacity to conduct armored
Warfare to defend his nation and he but
for months and months he was asking for
high and sophisticated air defense
systems to defend their energy
infrastructure and their big cities we
were just slow and that gave Vladimir
Putin a further green light to continue
his aggression his unprovoked invasion
of Ukraine and so President zielinski
should lay down what he thinks is
actually useful productive that can
deliver and then the West should put
itself in a place where when this is
over and and this there will come a day
when this is over we have a permanent
solution and I know there's nothing
permanent but think 5 10 20 years where
Vladimir Putin doesn't just declare a
ceasefire in six months or two years
from now we're right back in the soup
again very quickly Crimea does it go
back to Ukraine or do you think that
that is something that the Ukrainian
should let go
uh you know they'll have to sort through
it it will depend on how how much we are
able to help the ukrainians get to a
better place when I was in office I laid
down what became called the Crimea
declaration it is clearly part of
Ukraine I hope that Russia will come to
understand that you cannot take another
nation's Sovereign territory by Brute
Force okay and sir just I just want to
go on to U.S politics now thank you for
sharing your views about global politics
reading this book you come across as
someone who fills the Trump
Administration has unfinished business
you must be delighted he's running again
we do have unfinished business there is
much work to do in America and never
give an inch I mostly focused on those
four years the things that are
the external threats to the United
States but there's a lot of work for us
to do here at home as well our our
schools aren't teaching the kids what
they need to teach them there's a
philosophy on the rise that says somehow
America is a force for bad in the world
I know that's not true I know that
America is this incredibly special place
and Secretary of State I got to see
people depend on us lots left to do and
are you pleased that Trump has announced
he's running against uh I think
president Trump has made clear he
intends to run he'll go make his case to
the American people I'm confident that
there will be many others and for both
parties who will also believe they
should be the next leader I have
enormous confidence in the American
people that they'll sort it all out just
one more thing on this um sexy pompe in
the midterms were not good for Trump and
his candidates what is is he still the
de facto leader of the party or do you
think his grip is loosening on the
Republican Party
I don't spend a lot of time thinking
about these things I know it's the it's
the preoccupation of much of the world
in the media uh you talk about the
midterms it wasn't that President Trump
didn't do well that concerns me it's
that America didn't do well the
conservative Vision that I've been
working on for 30 years here in the
United States uh was not successful at
convincing the American people that it
was A Better Way Forward for all of them
the reason everyone's interested in the
U.S elections of course is because the
US is our Global leader so what happens
to your politics matters to all of us
and you talked about America not doing
well in the midterms and that brings me
on uh to January the 6th and what
happened in the last election because
America has always stood as a beacon of
democracy you are extremely proud of
this in your book yet you're the
administration under which you served
trash that part of the American brand
when it came to the legitimy of that
2020 presidential election yet yet in
your book you you barely talk about
either the Trump's attempt to overturn
that election or the January 6 2021
attack on the capital is that because
you felt ashamed of those episodes sir
no I was the Secretary of State and the
CIA director and so the book is focused
on how we delivered security abroad
as for but I'm happy to talk about
January 6 2021 uh it was a bad day at
the Capitol the security team there
failed to prevent these guys from riding
there I agree the world looks at that
and says goodness gracious what the
heck's going on in America and so that
part of the day I I regret it's terrible
when folks commit these kinds of acts of
violence and I hope they'll be
prosecuted appropriately for doing that
but make no mistake about it that night
America also showed its strength vice
president Pence finished the election we
had a peaceful transition of power but
Psy you famously said in the middle of
Trump's attempt to overturn that
Democratic vote that there would be a
smooth transition to a second Trump
Administration you've said since that
you were joking but but it was deadly
serious wasn't it it proved to be deadly
serious in what we saw happen uh and we
were all genuinely shocked around the
world to see this happening to a great
you know a great democracy do you regret
saying that now so so ma'am if you're if
you're just if you will take the time
when you put this out if you're sure the
whole statement I said that day it would
be greatly appreciated because taking a
little piece out of context uh is is the
worst you shouldn't do that to anyone to
read the whole statement I made that day
I spoke decently about the United States
of America we had had a tough election
we had things take place in that
election which weren't right which they
were we did not have a sufficiently
transparent election and I don't
describe it as being stolen but there
were lots of anomalies in our election
and we can't have that in the United
States okay so let me then worked I then
worked tirelessly I then worked
tirelessly to deliver that very peaceful
transition to my success for secretary
blinken and we actually executed that so
when you pull out this one when you pull
out this one comment you're just you're
not doing the world any service so I
guess misleading the world about what
actually happened to that day so do you
believe there was voter fraud in that
election oh yes oh absolutely there were
things that took place we we've had we
had hanging Chads in 2000 Hillary
Clinton still thinks the 2016 election
was stolen so we we had we have a number
of challenges we run a a very dispersed
election system and so we need to make
sure that when we're doing absentee
ballots and we have people that are out
collecting those ballots that we do so
in a way that we're confident that if
Sally is the city councilwoman she got
the most votes if Pete is the county
commissioner he got the most votes it is
incredibly important to our system that
we get that right and there were
certainly anomalies in that election as
we've had in many many of our elections
here in America and we should work to
fix them okay then you talk do you think
Biden stole that election
no ma'am I've never I've never used that
language at all so you think that we
have transparent we need to make sure we
have transparent elections where the
American people have confidence that
they know what transpired okay
in retrospect then when you look back on
that very difficult time do you regret
that you didn't stand up and call Trump
out more robustly around uh the
legitimacy of that election let me put
it to you that way sir
I've been very clear about my judgment
on the election I had I remember January
6th because I remember I had just 13
days left to deliver on behalf of the
American people and that's those last 13
days we're very busy we declared there
was genocide taking place in China we
delivered for the people of Taiwan in
those two weeks there was a lot of work
left to do and that was my central Focus
as it was for my whole four years I
understand but you were a leading voice
in that Administration and all I'm
asking you is do you regret now that you
didn't more robustly call out Donald
Trump uh for what he was saying around
the legitimacy of that election given
what happened subsequently which is you
say damaged the U.S reputation around
the world no ma'am I didn't say that the
that what happened there that day
damaged the United States reputation
around the world what in fact I said was
that we delivered a peaceful transition
on January 6 2021 exactly as our
constitution requires and that any time
there is political violence or for that
matter even non-political Islands in
America I do think others around the
world play on that it's absolutely true
sorry so do you but you don't think that
the storming of the capital and in the
world's greatest democracy and people
seeing democracy being undermined
potentially in that way I understand
that it was resolved you don't think
that undermined the U us around the
world and what you stand for
there is no Nation the equal of the
United States in its capacity to deliver
as a republican on Democracy period full
stop
as Secretary of State can you understand
I'm sorry ma'am I'm sorry I told your
team that we had to end seven minutes
ago sorry I apologize
um I've got one just final question for
you if you I mean yes ma'am yes ma'am I
wore seven we're seven minutes sorry can
I is a
I just wanted to say
um if you don't mind me saying this
voters might be forgiven for not quite
recognizing you at the moment because
you are and it's not because you're not
famous or known around the world it's
because you look quite different I hope
you don't mind me saying this it's a
complimentary uh remark
um you have lost an incredible amount of
Weights actually from pay can I just ask
you if you don't know how much have you
lost and how did you do it
so I lost about 90 pounds sadly I've put
some of it back on so pray for me to
stay healthy I did it just by eating
right and working out more old-fashioned
way and are you feeling really good now
I take it I I I do feel a heck of a lot
better thank you for asking uh I it's
been a struggle for my entire life and I
hope I can continue to be healthy to be
around for my grandkids and fit for
presidential run in 2024 perhaps uh but
I'll leave it there um sexual pump house
thank you so much for your time I'm very
grateful it was fascinating to talk to
you thank you sir
yes ma'am thank you so much for your
time today as well
a U.S government official responded to
this interview in a statement they told
me Mike Pompeo can't prove whether or
not Putin would have invaded Ukraine had
Trump been in the white house we do know
that Trump's approach to foreign policy
eroded Trust of allies and President
Biden repaired that they continued to
say President Biden has shown
significant and sustained leadership on
Ukraine and you study and deliberate
Cadence to bring allies on board Germany
has gone from supplying helmets to
leopard tanks that's quite a shift
that's Joe Biden keeping the Allies
together
I hope you enjoyed that conversation if
you scan this QR code on screen now you
can watch all of our interviews online
and all of the previous episodes of the
show
and if you scan this QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to it
instead the Beth Rigby's interview
podcast each week I take a look at the
highlights of my interviews and there's
some extra bits and pieces in there
about politics too that's on the Sky
News app or wherever you get your
podcasts
well that's it for today's show thank
you to my special guest Mike Pompeo and
thank you for watching
[Music]